tout faire pour se rapprocher de tout le
monde faire comprendre le monde de
l'entreprise s'était résumé l'idée
générale sortie de l'assemblée générale
du medef hier soir à mont gerald bonjour
bernard edwards
bonjour à vous et bonjour aux auditeurs
de martinique 1ère vous êtes le
président du medef martinique c'est à
savoir la section locale du mouvement
des entreprises de france faire
comprendre ce monde de l'entreprise sa
demeure le let motiv finalement des
présidents qui se succèdent chez vous je
crois que c'est indispensable non
seulement c'est indispensable mais c'est
nécessaire il faut rapprocher le monde
de l'entreprise à plusieurs niveaux au
niveau des politiques au niveau de
l'éducation nationale et je crois que
c'est dans cet environnement qu'on va
pouvoir trouver des solutions aux
problématiques qui sont les nôtres mais
de là quand même à évoquer cette
convention avec les parlementaires de
l'île une convention medef avec nos
représentants dans les plus hautes
sphères politiques européennes
il a fallu en arriver à cela pour qu'il
y ait davantage de contacts je crois que
oui et je crois que le monde des
politiques l'euro seront le ressentent
comme comme ça pourquoi cette convention
de dialogue
nos parlementaires ce sont nos
représentants aux instances nationales
que ce soit l'assemblée nationale ou
encore le sénat je crois qu'il faut un
dialogue franc et sans président hu et
sans préjugé aucun de façon à ce qu'on
puisse parler de manière naturelle et
quel que soit le bord politique et je
crois qu'il était important de le
formaliser au travers d'une institution
prend bien bernard edwards c'est qu'on
ait besoin de formaliser ce dialogue qui
devrait être naturel oui mais le
dialogue il faut il faut le seriez il
faut il faut donner des contours alors
je te raconte tout comme un quémandeur
s'est fait passé faire comprendre notre
réalité économique et notre réalité
économique on ne peut la comprendre que
si on vit l'entreprise dans son
intérieur alors ces conventions on y
trouvera croise à craindre à croix et
concrètement comment ça se passe et pour
réduire cette distance en voie politique
l'entreprise
l'entreprise ne doit pas à faire appel à
ses parlementaires comme je lé d'hier
soir qui a le feu faut arrêter que les
politiques fassent les pompiers et que
nous aussi dans des situations
difficiles
je crois qu'il faut poser clairement la
problématique de nantes
quiz en facial chômage on en parle
partout qui sait qu'on appelle les
entreprises
et comme je l'aï dit hier on demande aux
entreprises est au carrefour de tout
mais les entreprises ne pourront pas
être à tous les carrefours et je crois
que cette convention dialogue c'est une
c'est une charte voilà on va dialoguer
tous les problèmes qui sont les nôtres
que ça soit la grande entreprise la
moyenne entreprise ou la toute petite
entreprise
on a besoin que le monde politique se
rapproche des entreprises et inversement
alors il ya ce document donc signé il y
à un mois qui sera applicable d'ici
quelques jours une démarche à nous
expliquer le medef se rend dans les
instances européennes pour trouver des
fonds et permettre à des enseignants de
venir dans les entreprises a fait que
ceux ci rapporte aux élèves comment les
choses s'y passent c'est votre job de
faire ça je crois
puisqu'en fait la fin de la scolarité
qu'elle soit de plus haut niveau on
atterrit de deux manières dans le monde
de la vie sociétale si on peut dire soit
on devient chef d'entreprise soit on est
salarié et je crois que c'est 80% de
tous ceux qui font leur cursus scolaire
qui deviennent salariés et mais je crois
que si on apprend des lycées ce que
c'est vraiment d'entreprise je crois que
les futurs salariés intégrons les
entreprises avec une autre idée que
celle qu'on veut véhiculer au jour sur
veut si on veut être un petit peu
mauvaise londres on va dire que vous
préparez les consommateurs de demain
aussi
attendez je crois que tout le monde des
consommateurs à un niveau alors quand
vous vous demandez à bruxelles pour
demander des fonds qu est ce que vous
attendiez exactement que qu'on débloque
des sommes qui permettront à ces
enseignants de kits un peu sur quelques
heures leur cursus de deux salariés au
sein d'éducation nationale pour venir
chez vous alors recentrant le projet ce
projet s'appelle entreprises academy ce
projet va intéresser les élèves du lycée
à partir de la seconde jusqu'à la
terminale
puisqu'en fait ce sont trois années qui
passent très vite et puis l'élève se
pose la question c'est quoi mon soutien
et mon orientation de mai sera fait de
croix pour moi eh bien on veut intégrer
l'entreprise dans l'école et ça et ça
rejoint et sans avoir avait été est prêt
définir professionnelle dans les bacs
pros oui mais par le monde professionnel
mais les enseignants ils sont totalement
déconnectés de la vie de l'entreprise
elle meurt on va faire une immersion des
enseignants au sein des assemblées au
sein des entreprises et autres avoirs
d'un thème qui vont choisir roi dirigiez
ce qu'ils ont vu dans l'entreprise
auprès de leurs élèves jusqu'à qui
s'économise laissez pas les chefs
d'entreprise les enseignants oui alors
vous venez de répéter encore un bernard
fini et bernard aidera bernard grasset
d'impro ministre vous l'avez souligné
l'entreprise est au carrefour de tous
les élus les services de l'état les
collectivités le scolaire le sport
forcément lorsqu'on à carrefour on voit
tout on entend tout on ressent tous
comment va notre martinique selon vous
notre martinique comme je lé d'hier a
toujours son habit de nomade donc elle
est confrontée à nice à une instabilité
et je crois que il faut sortir de cette
instabilité
il ya une première approche par le
gouvernement les assises de l'outre-mer
c'est un espace de discussion le medef
et à participer maintenant il faut en
attendre leur tour autre élément dans la
vie économique des entreprises notamment
à la martinique même plus
particulièrement des entreprises de
l'outre-mer tout notre environnement
fiscal est remise en cause
la lodeom fin en 2000 en décembre 2006
une bonne chose ou pas que tout soit
remis en question que trouvent sont
remis à plat et qu'on compare le sauveur
de mêlée on n'est pas contre la
réflexion mais il faut savoir vers où
peut-on aller parce qu'une entreprise a
besoin de savoir d'avoir une visibilité
permanente pour est sûr qu'on ait fait
également les bilans des dispositifs
antérieurs mais je suis d'accord avec
vous mais on n'a pas cette visibilité
parce que la visibilité elle permet de
répondre à trop a donné comme disait le
président gattaz la croissance la
compétitivité la compétence et ce sont
ces trois données qui permettront aux
entreprises de répondre aux exigences de
sa fonction sociale
et est ce que le medef a les moyens de
faire comprendre au gouvernement aux
élus
ben qu'il faut ce temps de la réflexion
le temps de s'asseoir autour d'une table
pour tirer les bilans avant de tracer
une quelconque express a besoin
d'information dialogue
voilà il faut pas attendre le 31
décembre ou dialoguer il faut dialoguer
en permanence et répondre aux exigences
du moment et de façon à avoir des
perspectives réelles qui permettront de
répondre à nos données actuelles et vous
avez l'impression que ce gouvernement là
celui qui est là depuis manuel macron
vous avez l'impression que ce
gouvernement est à l'écouté du monde
économique
écoutez nous nous avons à la tête de
l'état un ancien d'olivier de
l'entreprise je crois qu'il connaît oui
maintenant je distingue la politique
économique et l'économie politique
oui alors vous avez évoqué quelques
difficultés qui arrive c'est le lot 1 la
vie amène son lot de contrariétés les
sens bien ce qu'ils vont anéantir tout
un pan de l'économie de maroc de la
martinique on le sait la saison
cyclonique avec ses aléas là on l'a vu
ce qui s'est passé avec les maria et
irma ça peut anéantir comme ça du coup
de souffle tout nous toute une économie
la perte démographique et donc la baisse
des dotations mais des challenges et des
enjeux également puisque on peut voir
des services des secteurs qui vont se
développer comme l'offre de services à
la personne à préparer
sauf qu on en parle depuis des années
oui on en parle depuis des années mais
la réalité des sargasses pour prendre ce
premier point depuis 2011
ça fait sept ans on a dit qu'on apprend
pensait que c'est un phénomène passager
aujourd'hui on constate qu'il est
récurrent et c'est parce qu'il devient
de plus en plus récurrents on s'en rend
compte il est à trois dimensions un
problème de santé publique
un problème d'économie et en plus ce
qu'on ressent pas quand c'est quelque
chose qu'il reviendra en permanence
jusqu'à les considérer aujourd'hui comme
une catastrophe
voilà le premier point sur les sargasses
donc je crois qu'il faut réunir toutes
les parties et nous avons préparé une
note à cette attention aux différents
parlementaires pour donner la vision de
l'entreprise sous la pluie matic des
sargasses je reviens aux services à la
personne
secteur à définir comme je vous le
disais sur le président du medef ça
aussi on en parle depuis des années ce
que vous voyez des contours se dessinent
et pas encore puisque le problème il je
dirais pas qu'il est neuf mais il n'est
pas récurrent mais il ya une il ya un
élément qu'on a pris en compte
il ya une baisse de la population mais
en même temps il les gens vivent plus
longtemps
il ya un vieillissement cinq ans que je
suis dans le métier 25 ans qu'on en
parle
oui mais il y a comme je disais tout à
l'heure
à qui la faute mais dans cette
construction il y aura également le
regard du medef national puisque au mois
de juillet durant renouvellement des
instances nationales on rappelle que le
medef c'est quand même une instance
consultative qui a droit de dialogue
avec les instances politiques se medef
national at il toutes les toutes les
cartes en main pour pouvoir parler de
nos pays de nos régions
absolument puisque j'ai davantage de
siéger au conseil exécutif et j'ai
l'avantagé de représenter l'ensemble des
outre-mer parce que c'est suffisant sait
déjà c'est déjà bien d'y être pour
parler pour faire valoir à la fois nos
difficultés mais à la fois nos atouts et
je vous rappelle qu'en janvier 2017 il y
avait on avait fait paraître le document
france outre-mer 2020 qui donnait un
petit peu notre vision sur les dix
prochaines années une situation sur veut
un peu raccourci les données mais je
crois qu'avec la nouvelle présidente ce
qui lui arrive et puisque les élections
au medef national c'est le 3 juillet
prochain
ce que j'ai aimé c'est qu'on a donné la
parole aux outre-mer
chaque candidat à la présidence ils sont
six ont été entendus par le comité autre
rêve et ils sont conscients qu'il ya
quelque chose vraiment une vision
particulière à voir sur nos télés il ya
une vision mais il faut que ça se
cultive
ça ne peut se cultiver que par nous
merci beaucoup d'avoir été ce matin avec
nous bernard edwards recul président du
medef martinique merci d'un repli dans
son crédit bonne journée merci à vous